[Music]
there we are
me and my best friends in the whole
world
playing card games on a lazy day
i'll never forget those good old days
they were the best days of my entire
life look at us
henry was always sort of the leader of
our little gang
he'd sit there at the table dealing
cards and telling stories for hours
he was a real character
and pally who could forget pally with
his lucky blue cap
and oh that sly grin
hallie was the funniest guy i ever met
and then there was me
i wasn't the leader of the gang and i
certainly wasn't the jokester
no sir in those days i was known most
for my sweet tooth
yes i sure loved candy
i loved candy
i really really did
but not quite as much as tad
look at him
old tad
sitting there at the card table eating a
hershey bar
playing cards with henry and paulie
yep that's him all right
those three guys were the best henry and
his car dealing bally with his blue cap
and tad with his candy bar
you were just such a great bunch of guys
i was so happy i could hang out with
them
i'm sure you can tell by that look on my
face
oh god
look at me
sitting there
just a few feet behind tad
with my black jacket
my blue jeans
my glasses my black sneakers with the
green socks peeking right out
that's me all right
yeah
i gave a smile and a little finger point
and then i just laughed with my hands in
my lap
[Applause]
what a day it was indeed
hands behind the old head
yeah cross the legs why not
but then
something
crazy came over me
so i stood up
and i walked right over to the guys
and you know what i did
i reached out my hand to dad
tad's the one in the plaid shirt of
course
i shook his hand
and you know what he did
he gave me a piece of candy
oh baby your peppermint batty
i gotta take a bite of this thing
i took the biggest bite i'd ever taken
pretty much got the whole thing in my
mouth
oh boy
i felt a little sick rubbed my thumb
well i wanted to thank ted so i gave him
a little pat on the head
i didn't want the other guys to feel
left out so i patted them on the head as
well
hey what the heck i give myself a pat on
the head
[Music]
and to show off my coordination i kept
patting my head while rubbing my
stomach enough showboating i thought
it was time to show my best buddies what
they really meant to me
so i reached into my pocket and i took
out my wallet
i had to look a little bit
was it
the jacket or the pants i mean i know i
had my wallet there it is
i took that old brown wallet
and i handed it right to the guys
[Laughter]
they nodded and said thanks
hey you know why wouldn't i give them my
wall they're my best friends and i want
to show them what they meant to me the
only problem is
they didn't feel quite the same
they took that wallet and they took off
leaving me all alone
a walletless sucker
but still
it was the best day of my life
december
2nd 2011.
well
that's the end of my memoir have a good
night
[Applause]